Film Courage: Sean what came first, the decision to
make the movie Tangerine or the decision
to shoot on an iPhone? Sean Baker, Filmmaker of Starlet, Tangerine, The Florida Project: The decision to
make tangerine came long before the
decision is shoot on the iPhone that was
a shooting on the iPhone was something
that we eventually got to because when
we started budgeting the film and
looking at how we're going to make this
on the limited budget that we had that
option eventually arose so I say the
idea of Tangerine came long before and
also to the beauty of the iPhone being
less conspicuous than using this right I
wish that I could say that I I knew
about all the benefits that the iPhone
was going to reveal to us and yeah I
wish I knew about no I'm sorry let me
start over I I wish I I could say that I
I was going about this intentionally and
and I was going to embrace all the
benefits that the iPhone would be giving
us but quite honestly a lot of those
benefits were revealed to us while we
were shooting and we just we just took
advantage of them and then we made the
most of what we had but but it was it
was really started from a place of like
a budgetary constraint did anyone try to
talk you out of shooting on a knife Oh
most definitely
we had many people you know when I when
I mentioned it for the first time to
some of my producers you know all the
eyebrows were being raised I mean I I
even had the can I was trying to talk
myself out of it to tell you the truth I
am and once I convinced myself then I
had to convince the rest of the crew but
we did it by doing tests we shot a lot
of tests and at one point Technicolor
was nice enough to allow us to bring
some footage over there and blow it up
on the big screen to present it to our
finance ears and our producers and just
know that this thing
hold resolution look presentable on the
big screen and it forgive me when I came
over today I was thinking that was one
of the first few films to be shot on a
feature film but apparently it's not and
that's nothing that you've ever made a
statement on you've always write shit
down true I don't know how many films
have been shot on the iPhone a handful
maybe maybe maybe even two I'm not sure
but I do we never said we were one of
the I mean we never said we were the
first iPhone movie
I actually know the makers of another
one called King Kelly that came out in
2012 that was at South by Southwest it's
a wonderful movie it's very different
but they shot on an earlier version of
the iPhone and they were going for a
very different aesthetic but we can say
that we are the first iPhone film shot
and true scope yes because we had the
anamorphic adapters given to us by
Moondog labs oh nice okay and so how
does that work with the lens like on the
iPhone well we I first off I found them
because of a Kickstarter campaign they
were in their prototype stage and they
were trying to get money to actually get
this product up and out there right so I
reached out to them and they they were I
had to drop mark Duplass his name of
course and but they were very happy to
lend us three of their prototypes they
sent him over basically what it does is
that you're still using the iPhone lens
it's just an adapter that fits over the
lens and allows you to capture your
image anamorphic Lee so you once you
when you are actually looking at the
image on the iPhone which is basically
our monitors on set everything is
squished so you know how in the old days
you would watch film on television
you're watching Western and everything
during the credits sequence had to be
squished in order to read everything
that's how everything looked while we
were shooting we always had to imagine
what the frame would look like once it
stretched out then when you get home and
you're in post-production you get the
footage on your computer
yeah we'll stretch it out and see
either way that the final product will
be so yeah yeah it was um it was it was
interesting we radium and I radium Chung
and I we coast shot the film radium
shown with is a wonderful
cinematographer and and and solo shot my
previous film starlet we shared duties
this time just because of schedule and
also we wanted we both wanted to be
camera operators on this but anyway he
we were joking around on set about how
we had to get so used to imagining what
the final frame would look like and how
it would stretch out but then we thought
you know that's how it was done back in
the day I'm sure that's how Sergio Leone
was doing it's you know where he would
have to look at probably a squished
image they didn't have the technology to
to have monitors on set and stretch this
thing out properly I mean so it's we're
doing the same thing that people were
doing only like for 30 40 years ago so
it was fine but were there certain
things then that when you did look at
the stretched image you realize oh you
know what we need to go back and shoot
that because we missed some little vinyl
thing or the most part we were okay
we're okay
and remember there were only a few shots
in which we had to be incredibly
accurate with framing because the film
still has sort of a docu thing going on
which allowed for a handheld material so
you know you could always be slightly
you didn't have to be absolutely perfect
there were a few segments within the
film that are that are locked down and
and in which the framing is extremely
precise and calculated and now and in
those cases now we were fine I think by
the time we got to those sections we
were pretty confident we knew what we
were doing
that being said do you think you'll go
back and shoot another film on the
iPhone no no no no no well I mean you
never know where you're gonna be but I
enjoyed the experience and it was fine
and
I know that already in the in the in the
last year and a half you know the
technology has advanced to the point
where you can already and and the app
that we used which is called filmic Pro
that's already on another version or two
since we shot and you can capture 3k on
it and so already in the year and a half
advancements is taking place within the
iPhone you know filming community and
and and and and devices that may I'm
sorry and apps and tools that you can
actually you know get something better
than what we got but at the same time I
do fall into the camp of if you can
shoot film shoot film that's that's me I
just haven't been able to for the last
couple films because of budget my goal
is always to try to get the budget to
shoot on celluloid again before it goes
away entirely so that's what I'm trying
to do with the next film you know but
well you never know you can never say
sure I mean if you ask me while I was
making starlet if I would be shooting
the next film on an iPhone I would be
outraged I would you know no way in the
world I would have considered it it
actually the whole reason that this came
about is tangerine in general is because
for a year and a half after starlet I
was waiting for a much bigger budget
film to happen and it was a completely
different subject matter and it was a
full script that was ready to go that we
were looking for a cast for but it's
very hard to get cast without financing
and it's very hard to get financing
without cast so we were in this terrible
cycle that kept going on for about a
year and a half until the point where I
knew I had to make something and or I
would just be sitting around for the
rest of my life so I called up Mark
Duplass and I said you know a couple
years ago you you put it out there that
you would like to executive produce a
micro budget for me is that's offer
still on the table and he said yeah
what's your idea and I said Santa Monica
and Highland I think you might know the
intersection he said yeah yeah get me a
treatment and we'll talk about it
so just real quickly when when you
realize that this other one may not
happen because you were caught in this
weird zone what was that like before you
said you know what I I need to get
something going here fast like what do
you go through well to tell you the
truth it came down to two things I
looked at a lot of filmmakers around me
who were being quite prolific at the
time in particular I I looked at the
cinema of like Joe Swanberg and I just
was very impressed with how fast he was
making films also the Korean director
Kim ki-duk he was just seem to have one
every year and so I thought you know yet
they're there because they were so
prolific they've actually they've gotten
attention for this and and the people
who weren't making things worse are
slowly falling off the radar and I felt
I was slowly falling off the radar so
this was a a desperate move for me to to
continue working number one and number
two I went to UM I was I was still on
the tail end of the starlet festival run
because you know that can actually run
up to two years sometimes you know it's
really because you'll still get requests
from film festivals almost two years
down the line and so and I loved to
travel with film festivals it's very
important to me because making these
independent films there really isn't any
money in these nice movies and the
compensation for me is travel and seeing
the world anyway I got to go to New
Zealand wonderful Film Festival
absolutely like wonderful programming
because there shortly after can so they
get a lot of the canned titles so I'm
there just for two weeks watching all
these moves but then I started watching
all of course that you know the big
canned titles but then all of a sudden I
found myself also watching a lot of the
smaller independence like a lot of the
Australian Indies and and and they were
made for very little and and I thought
you know these these are inspiring me
you know why
another small film I mean I was I was
looking there were a lot of first and
second time films and this selection and
and I which I just loved how it seemed
like there was that spirit that these
filmmakers had with their films of like
just getting out there for the first
time in doing it no matter what no
matter you know with the very little
money they had and I thought you know
that's basically par like I'm on my
fifth film but still I'm I'm I have to
retain that spirit or I'll die so it was
it was that it was at the New Zealand
Film Festival that I remember making the
decision saying I'm gonna go back to the
states and I'm going to now focus on a
whole new project and that's why I give
the entire staff at in New Zealand Film
Festival thanks in the end credits of
tangerine how much did marketing factor
into your decision to shoot on the
iPhone actually it didn't factor into it
whatsoever I mean we couldn't even get
we got I think we reached out to iPhone
at one point to see if they would even
lend us or give us iPhones to shoot and
perhaps whatever department we reached
out to didn't they declined I think it
was probably because of the subject
matter being the fact that it was
focusing on sex work so we knew that
perhaps the the film would get attention
because of it to a certain degree but it
wasn't in any way calculated or planned
it wasn't something for example the most
we really wanted to actually keep it out
of the news until we premiered at
Sundance we didn't want people going
into Sundance thinking I'm gonna go see
this iPhone movie nobody knew actually
until the very end of the film when the
final credits it says showed me iPhone
5s and that was the first time anybody
outside our small circle knew that this
film was shot on that so then when you
do the QA yeah afterwards right for most
of the questions directed toward no
50/50 right now what seems to happen in
these Q&A is is that 50% of it is
about the tech and then 50% of a of it
is about the trans movement and how we
approached that sensitive subject matter
and being from outside that world how we
decided to to actually form a story work
with our with our actors and and and
make this film is there a way you could
share like take five minutes to share
with any filmmakers that have never felt
the iPhone they want to shoot a feature
film
sure there are a few things I'd
recommend first off every film is
different so I sometimes don't like
giving advice because if I do I'm
talking about one particular aesthetic
you know what I mean so but but if there
are a few things that I would suggest
filmmakers do if they're using on the I
would feel using the iPhone and one of
them is get a stabilizer you try to
handhold an iPhone it really does look
terrible in my eyes you may want to go
for that look but because the lens is so
tiny no matter how stable you think you
might be the human hand shakes and that
translates pretty poorly when it gets
onto the big screen there's a wobbly
sort of this this very unattractive
shakiness that's that can be fixed if
you have a stabilizer so we used a
smoothie which is that's what it's
called it's a smoothie by Steadicam and
tiffin and it's really just a little
grip it's about an 8 inch grip and you
know it's a Steadicam for an iPhone so
that and then also sound you know sounds
very important on any production I get a
lot of Twitter messages and Facebook
messages asking me how I record it on
the iPhone when I say I didn't record
any high phone we we recorded
professionally separately and we sunk in
post you know ayran Strauss had a full
was our sound recordist wonderful varied
talented artists he he basically was
able to he recorded everything the way
he would normally record on any feature
film with his digital unit and his hot
very high quality mics both you know
both shotgun mics and lavalieres and
then we sunk in post and that's very
important because you know an audience
will they can accept anything visually
because that is sort of like this
aesthetic that you're presenting to the
audience but with this sound isn't there
the sound isn't crisp and easy to hear
and understand it's it's a no-go so
spend money on on your sound and do it
properly and those are the two things
that I would say will get you
technically there and then just in terms
of just generally approaching iPhone
filmmaking I would say we're at such an
early stage of using you know almost
like devices that aren't cameras to make
films that you can do whatever you want
that's the thing that's we just
experimented and we just said what
benefits are to be found here and let's
just try different things you know you
can get this little device into us into
nooks and crannies that you wouldn't be
able to get you know a big camera into
you can you can they're so lightweight
you can move them easily you can throw
them on a drone and and get your nice
aerial shots you can do whatever you
want we just you know we we just started
experimenting there during production
and in tangerine is what resulted but
I'm sure you know a filmmaker out there
who you know just wants it to to come up
with their own aesthetic it's very easy
to because it's
it's it's it's quite this thing is
actually look at it I'm just throwing it
around right now I'm not you can't do
that with a 35-millimeter camera that's
the big difference what's the first day
like writing a screenplay for you when
you have these different ideas in mind
take out because today was basically one
of those days oh great that's like I
just got off the phone before you came
over um you know I I can't even I mean I
it's just throwing ideas around at first
and crisper gosh who co-wrote Starla and
tangerine he's wonderful at you know
note-taking so he's there typing away
just compiling every note possible into
something I don't know even know what
he's typing what you know simple text or
something he's just compiling all these
notes so the first day is really just us
brainstorming spitballing ideas right
but but there must be something in you
that's like okay I think I'm ready to
commit a good to plus maybe years of my
life to this and so you you're already
set on the idea yeah and you you know
that you want to do it so then you're
sort of stream-of-consciousness thinking
and he's taking notes and then at some
point how do you formulate that into
like a first page that's really hard to
say because it takes it's over the
course of many months you know so I I
think there there's a point where there
are enough notes down on page and you
you understand your story enough where
it's time to start writing those pages
so I might write a page he'll write a
page we will start sharing them I know
that we used for both films I think we
used Google Drive and we were sharing a
lot that way you know we also go about
it where we eventually get to a point
where we we have the the post-its on the
wall and that that that's when you when
you actually can get a film or your idea
your you know your script up on the wall
and like with hundreds of posts
then it makes sense from beginning to
end I think that's when we decide to
start a signage other pages and scenes
so we'll say okay you look at that scene
I think I got a handle on that scene
I'll take that can you take that one
because I don't have a handle on that
one and then we share them and then we
start to compile this thing and that's
how that's that's how that's done what
would you say is the most important part
of the screenwriting process for you
whether it's creating that conflict
whatever ten minutes half hour in to the
opening whatever it is mm-hm the third
act yeah that's really a difficult
question would you say you know the
ending I almost always know the endings
of every one of these movies before we
even set down the road to you know just
start breaking it breaking it out point
by point I mean I knew the ending of
starlit I knew the ending of tangerine I
know the ending of the next film so
that's because I just I I think endings
are very important to me
prints the same goes for prints at
Broadway and take-out so with all of
them I knew the ending was almost more
important than the beginning this is the
first time I'm thinking about this sort
of stuff so so I haven't been asked
these questions before so but ya know I
think it's actually I focused more on
the last scene and the impact the last
scene will have that's almost one of the
first things I think about you know with
tangerine it was the only thing we
thought about when I went to you know to
start our research process Chris bruh
gosh and I went to the corner of Santa
Monica and Highland and we started
introducing ourselves to people etc you
know just
and what we're gonna do when we finally
found my aunt Kiki I said I only have
like a few ideas here and one of them is
well first off it has to take place on
one day because we have a limited budget
and costume changes costs money and
continuity cost money it's easier to
shoot and it's one of the film that
takes place in a 24 hour period time the
second one is that I think people are
coming together or someone's trying to
find somebody else or whether that's a
love story or a revenge story I don't
know and the third is this ending I know
I can see the ending I can see all my
characters converging at the end at
donut time in a big climactic scene
those were the only things I saw going
into it so it's funny yeah it's funny
you say thank you bring that out back
the endings are very important to me
because it's about how the audience
leaves the theaters you know I I think
very much so about the impact of that
last scene if you think I look at my
favorite films and my favorite films are
like Harold and Maude and when he's
walking away at the end after you know
the the car goes over the cliff and you
think he might be in it but then he's up
on the cliff and he's with his banjo you
have you know some most of my favorite
films have such incredibly memorable
lasting scenes that have an impact on
the audience as they're sitting there
during the final credits and I think
that that's something I'm always
conscious of it's a it's it's the most
important thing for me in a screenplay
looking back on the five feature films
that you've made you've also worked on a
few television series what year or what
years would you say were the toughest on
you where you thought you know what this
is too hard and I'm gonna have to find
something else to do this isn't as
glamorous as I thought it would be or my
wanting to tell a story this is too
emotional for me
that's interesting that's an interesting
question I I think we could almost every
time
you wrap up a film there's that period
between between films that you're losing
confidence every day after the release
of the first time you've premiered as a
festival and the confidence level starts
to go down of like how am I going to
continue this what's again I'm now again
for making another film again oh my god
maybe I'm not you know I I'm a good
barista so I could always go that way
but I but then of course then the film
gets released in theaters and your
confidence level goes back up but then
every day after the release date it
slowly goes down so III have to say that
it's not just one time or one year it's
always post release of the film that
you're most vulnerable and you're most
insecure at least for me would you say
it gets progressively more emotional
with each film that you've done it
depends on the subject matter okay you
know I think that this film was for me
very it was it it took its toll it
wasn't yeah it really was because of the
world that we were working in and the
fact that we were working with real
people off the streets sometimes not our
leads but you know there were others in
the film that we're actually coming from
that world and the hardship that they've
had to deal with in poverty and you know
that this this film took its toll do you
have advice for other filmmakers or even
actors who were going through that
they've come off something that's
successful but as each day happens
within the 24 hour news feed their thing
gets buried more and more and more I
kind of understand what you're saying I
I'm dealing right now with because but
things have changed over the years the
way that you get feedback from
people and audience members critics etc
it's it's changed now it's all about
social media in the past you had to wait
for printed you know reviews etc now
you're getting during q and A's you
would find out what people like now it's
literally like I get a tweet seconds
after the movie you know as soon as the
lights came up in the theater so I am
you know I deal with that a lot because
I focus on the negative reactions it's
just something that's my personality I I
haven't even there are some wonderful
reviews and people are selling haven't
you you haven't read that review it I'm
like no I'm focusing on the the rotten
tomato not the fresh thyme it's it's
something it's just masochistic or
something but I but and you're right
though about the way that things get the
positivity might get buried by suddenly
a lot a load of negative tweets but then
the positive ones come back so it's you
got a I'm starting to be able to cope
but but what can you do you're not going
to please anyone everyone and then on
top of that it's like I look at the
films that I love my favorite films and
they've divided audiences uh-huh you
know fifty-fifty I mean there are some
of my favorite films people have walked
out at or booed at it can you know and
so I can't concern myself with pleasing
every single person and plus the subject
matter that we're normally covering with
my films they they fall along a
political viewpoint and if you're not
and if there are gonna be plenty of
people there who don't agree with me
politically on some of these movies it's
just a simple fact and and so that'll
divide people and it's something that I
can't get too concerned about them it's
just it's it's the way things are so no
I get it anybody myself included can
call themselves a bloggers or
journalists and just put up their own
yeah
and and I've no sort of merit to do that
I guess what I'm saying is any advice
for that in-between time where you kind
of say to yourself Wow was this my peak
because I think there's a scary moment
and and so much of LA is you're only as
good as your last whatever oh yeah and
so how do you deal with that well that's
that's that's a scary thing it's just
it's I must say it's it's a scary thing
I mean you are always looking to top the
last film you have or whatever your
project is or if you're a comedian your
last set if you're a musician your your
last show it's it's you have to always
strive for that you're not gonna try it
you don't try to match the last one you
try to beat the last one you know
because at least you know you've put
you've put your all into it I that was a
big deal with this film because the fact
that we had to actually we didn't we was
half the budget less than half the
budget of my previous film tangerine was
less than half the budget of starlet
then all of a sudden we found ourselves
shooting on the iPhone it got to the
point where I think in some some
people's eyes we were gonna make a film
that was less than the one before but
see I I read one review that actually
kind of I'm affected by reviews and I am
I'm sorry that's just me and there was
one review that said that starlet was
less ambitious than Prince a Broadway
which I didn't agree with but that did
affect me so this film was intentionally
more ambitious than starlet or at least
highly attempted more ambition so so
yeah I'm I'm vulnerable that way what
can you do but but I did but but they're
getting back to the iPhone thing it does
relate to what I just said because I
won't say who said this but somebody
said this when I asked them to come work
on tangerine and I said we were shooting
on the iPhone and this is after I
already had convinced myself that it was
okay they said okay Shawn yeah I'll come
to LA and
play with you and I said no no no you
can't use that word play please don't
use that word play because if we look at
it that way we're gonna fail from day
one you know we have to look at this
film as just as important as anything
else we're doing and we have to strive
to make this thing as good if not better
than the previous one so the play word
no we're not playing here that was so so
that but that always at that that way of
thinking has to be applied to every film
out there you know and do you have
anything you do to get you out of sort
of the industry for an hour and then
come back to it because sometimes in
social media it's like I have to write I
know it's true it's true no it's funny
because I'm also a cinephile and I try
to watch a film a day so I'm still in
cinema even if I'm not working on my own
thing I'm watching somebody else's thing
so it becomes to the point where it's
it's sensory overload that's again why I
try to you know travel with these film
festivals because that gives me a break
that gives me a break where I get to be
put somewhere I've never been before and
I get to explore a place a city usually
where it's like it's a whole new it's a
that's my moment of a break and removing
myself but on a daily basis I hike I
hike up but Runyon Canyon which is about
you know a quarter of a mile that
direction I go there with my dogs and my
girlfriends so that's uh that's a nice
break where you have an hour and a half
of shutting off well I have to admit
sometimes I look down on my phone but
yeah that's where we're at these days
these this this this device has
unfortunately made us I think this
entire society have a case of a Dede
because we're weak it's very difficult
to go
more than 20 minutes without looking at
it
your you have this internal yeah I know
I'm sorry have you have this internal
alarm clock that wakes you I got not
this is crazy this is scary and this is
where I think I may need to go off the
grid for a little while but two nights
ago when it was you know that was we're
speaking right now on the Monday after
the release of my film which was on
Friday I think on Friday night I woke up
my body woke myself up at 3:00 a.m. just
to check Twitter
that's how yes asifa's for the reactions
I'm getting so it's something that is
very different from the way you you used
to you know get reactions about your
work and it's something that I don't
know whether that's a good thing it
can't be a good thing if your body's
waking you up to 3:00 a.m. in the
morning you know what I'm saying so it
can be I think it can get a little
dangerous we're all gonna have to learn
how to live with you know constantly
being plugged in and also - there's a
constant state of comparison going on
because they're not looking at our own
thing we're looking at oh this was said
by this actor about this actor or
whatever and we're feeding into that
mindset you know what I know I when I
did my I don't I think competition is is
ridiculous meaning in terms of like
getting jealous about somebody else's
achievements that you should I think in
this I think in this independent film
community we have we're all making such
different movies it doesn't matter we
should all be supportive of one another
and and be happy that we're all getting
our visions out there I mean I you know
I love the fact that I I'm making very
different films from you know the safty
Brothers and the guys have borderline
from you know all the other wonderful
filmmakers that you know I was just at
Sundance with this year and we're making
very different movies but yet I think we
respect each other's stuff and
like and and we're just happy that we're
able to all continue down that this road
of like trying to you know to see what
we can do with this generation with with
cinema so you know it's it's uh it's
it's nice to see that it's nice to see
that's why I live in Los Angeles now
because I see this sort of like
independent film community getting very
supportive and growing and here in the
city and and in that sense of community
I haven't really seen for a while we're
nowhere near like the collectives that
existed in like the seventies and stuff
like that or but but it would be nice if
we got there Sean what's the most or one
of the most exciting moments you've had
as a filmmaker there have been many
exciting moments over the years but
there's this one small moment I had by
myself while living in New York a few
years ago I used to go down to Chinatown
go to Grand Street and go through all
the bootleg imports and see what I could
find from new Asian cinema because it's
sometimes hard to find you know and I
found a copy of takeout which was nice
yeah I felt like I made it you know my
film was bootlegged over there I made it
all the way back back to me and now I'm
I'm purchasing a bootleg of my own film
and I it just was like okay good I the
film got out there now of course I
shouldn't be so happy that my film was
bootleg but at the same time when you're
making these little movies it's just
nice to know that you know it's getting
outside your living room didn't you
bought that copy
I actually went up to the woman at the
counter I'm like this is my this is my
film that's my name okay can I at least
like have this one and she no she didn't
know what I was talking about really if
there's a language barrier but at the
same time I I did pay for it yeah that's
the other exciting moments I was pretty
exciting yeah I mean that's yeah I I
mean the this last I have to say with
tangerine though you may want to bring
back to tangerine tangerine for me
had many exciting moments you know our
premiere at Sundance our you know just
the the days of getting a nice reaction
to the film those 12 days at Sundance
were just they're just a whirlwind but
just recently a week and a half ago when
we were in New York City doing preparing
for the release of the film Kiki and
Maya came to New York and we actually
had Magnolia made us a float a tangerine
float for the Pride Parade and it was
really just this wonderful moment where
you know Kiki who had not who's never
been outside of Southern California you
know it was suddenly experiencing
Manhattan from this elevated point of
view in you you couldn't ask for more
than that I mean I was just so happy
that you know Kiki was there and being
able to experience this wonderful moment
and and I thought I was like in a way
like experiencing the moment through her
because I couldn't imagine seeing
Manhattan that way for the first time
with thousands of people cheering you on
and either side of a Fifth Avenue and
Brighton so it's just an incredible
moment